- Oh, my gosh, I'm such a fan.
I'm gonna keep it cool.
- Oh same.
- I'm gonna be so cool
you're not even gonna know.
So, but you're from a small town.
I am as well, but it's
a small town in Ireland.
So like, what was it like,
like how small are we talking?
- Well, I'm really from a
village that's outside of a town.
So the village-
- You don't even get town?
- We don't get town.
No.(laughing)
It's like we had a school,
we had a church, we had-
- [Kelly] Just one?
- Uh huh, one post office
and then of course,
'cause it's Ireland, we had two pubs.
Just to balance things out.
- One church two pubs.(laughs)
- [Katrina] Yeah.
- I love it. I love it.
So how did you get into acting,
cause did you always live
acting when your kid,
were you exposed to it?
- Yeah.
It's one of those things,
I think you're sort of born
with this crazy the desire to.
- Like kind of innate
feeling (indistinct).
- Yeah, and I was one of
those annoying little kids,
I was always running around the house,
kind of doing impressions
and annoying everybody
and I think it just was inevitable
and when I finished school,
it was like, right,
I'm gonna go to college, which I did.
And then, I sort of took
a detour for a long time,
but it I got back to
it about 10 years ago.
- Oh I Love that.
I love that.
Well, I'm so happy you did.
I love you.
Well, so wait, you had
a son last year, right?
- Not even six months,
Not even six months ago.
(audience clapping)
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah.
- Six months.
So how early did you go back to work?
- Eight weeks.
- [Kelly] What!
- But was just fresh, but still, yeah.
- Okay. I did three months,
I took three months
and I still think I should have take more.
- [Katrina] It's crazy.
- It's a lot.
I mean (indistinct)
- Like the sleep training,
the trying to get everything
- Well, sleep training.
We're just going through now,
because I don't know.
I think like everybody you sort
of get into bad habits and-
- Oh no. What was yours?
- I mean, not putting him down awake,
this whole thing of like-
- Oh (indistinct)
- Yeah. The way has explained to me is
that you're giving a gift to them. Right?
- Exactly.
- Because I think-
- That's why it was explained
- As a parent, you're
sort of like so anxious
and you're like,
"Oh my God, they're crying.
I need to like step in."
- Yeah.
- But you're stopping them learning
is a really important skill, so.
- And somebody told me
that literally it's like
the one everybody gives you
so many books and so much advice
and it's like the one
thing that really stuck.
But speaking of motherhood
and "Belfast" you play the character of ma
so what was the character
like your mother at all?
Did you, were you inspired by her at all?
- Yeah, very much.
I think it's one of those things
when I first read the script,
she just felt so familiar to me
and she, you know Irish women,
I think a lot of mamis anyway
have this kind of ferocity
about them, very quick to laugh,
but sometimes quick to anger and-
- [Kelly] Yeah. Passionate.
That's what we call that.
Yeah.(laughs)
- Yeah. And so,
there was times when I would be on set
and there's one really funny scene
where a lovely little Jude Hill,
who's just incredible.
Where his character buddy steals something
and he gets into trouble.
And so she starts going after him,
she's chasing him up the stairs.
And I had one of those flashbacks
where I'm like,
"Oh God, I remember this(chuckles)
I remember chased by my mom.
You know like. (laughing)
- Yeah. Oh, I was too.
And you'll chase yours as well.(laughing)
- [Katrina] Yeah. Yeah.
- It's good.
Puts a little veer.
- [Katrina] Yeah.
- You gotta get in trouble-
- It's a healthy dose. Right?
- Yeah a healthy dose.
So we saw some other work
you did earlier in lockdown
and well, let's watch.
(upbeat music)
- Captain's log.
It has been 500 spaces, since captain.
Our captain and my lover went missing.
Our searches letter to
the galaxy quadrant.
Will (indistinct) and Sandra
are investigating the list.
No whereabouts of captain.
The (indistinct) planet.(indistinct)
(audience applauding)
- I really wish I could have
been in lockdown with you.
Cause you're so fun.
That was amazing.
The microwave was my
favorite part.(laughing)
So advanced.
What is that?
What's that show?
- So Kevin and Ross mains
two guys in Scotland.
They sort of wrote and edited this.
And then my really good friend, Steve Cree
who was an Outlander with me,
he roped a lot of us into this thing
and it was just like
we were all in lockdown
and nobody was doing anything.
So it was like,
"Do you wanna do something
really silly and really fun?"
And it was like, "Of course."
- Absolutely.
- Like, "Let's do it.
Let's do our own makeup.
Let's use kitchen utensils
and let's have a show.
But it was like everyone from
James McEvoy, Florence Pew,
like we had a stellar cast.
- [Kelly] A game?
- Yeah.(indistinct)
- What's the name?
Is it "StarForce."
Of course.
- There is no copyright right.
We're fringing on anybody's.
(both laughing)
I'm sure, actually now that
people are actually seeing this,
we might have to give some props
to some of the footage they've stolen
from other places, but
you know that's all good.
- But it's fine.
It was COVID.
It was a pandemic.
Thank you so much, Katrina.
I'm such a fan and you're so lovely.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
Such a pleasure
- Congrats on your little one.
That's so exciting.
It's an exciting time.
Everybody you can see
"Belfast and Theaters"
all "On Demand" and it's
out on "Blueray" March 1st.
And get ready for season
six of "Outlander" y'all.
(audience applauding)
so is Everyone.
(background noise drown all other sounds)